Hi, I'm Filip from the
Google Chrome Apps team.
Chrome apps and extensions
use familiar web technologies,
and can be installed on the
desktop, or any Chrome OS
device.
These client apps have
access to additional APIs
not available to
ordinary web pages.
A common problem
developers face,
is how to get the latest
data from their server
to the client app.
Say you're building
an application
to track play-by-play
stats for the World Cup.
One way to get an
update is by polling.
Your client can periodically
check with the server
to get the latest data.
But it doesn't know when
new data is available.
So sometimes it will
come back with nothing,
while sometimes it will
get the updates long
after the data is
actually available.
That's not great.
It needlessly consumes
network bandwidth, grounds
down the device's battery,
and delivers a poor experience
to the user who wants to the
game updates as they happen.
Good news--
chrome.gcm API allows
you to access Google
Cloud Messaging
service to solve that problem.
So how can you do it better?
You can tell your World
Cup tracker server
which clients need to be
notified as data becomes
available, and use GCM to push
the data to the right clients.
And how is that done?
Through GCM
downstream messaging.
First your app
registers with GCM,
indicating the sender ID of the
application server, from which
it wants to receive
the messages.
It receives the
registration ID in return.
Next, your application
sends the registration
ID to the server,
followed by information
about teams or games the
user is interested in.
As games progress, your
server sends messages
with the right registration ID
to GCM, and GCM does the rest.
Your upper extension
does not even
need to be running at the
time the message is sent,
because once the message
is received by Chrome,
it will start your app and
trigger chrome.gcm on message
event.
That's how you can make
sure your users are not
going to miss that big game.
And if Chrome is offline when
your server sends the message,
that's not a problem
either, because when
GCM receives messages
from your server,
it stores them in a queue.
Once the device is
back online, GCM
delivers the queued messages,
and Chrome fires chrome.gcm
on message event in your app.
If Chrome cannot be reached
for a long period of time,
the messages could be dropped,
either there because they
exceeded their time to live, or
the queue size limit was hit.
In the latter case,
a special message
will be sent to the application,
triggering chrome.gcm
on messages delete event, to
let you know that it happened
and allow you to
handle that situation.
OK, that's downstream messaging.
Now let's talk about delivering
messages from your client app
to the server.
Without GCM, your client app
might be conducting the app
server through
XML http requests.
But if the user doesn't
have the network connection
at the moment, that request may
have to be repeated many times.
Again, that's a very
inefficient use of resources.
Luckily chrome.gcm
API offers the ability
to send upstream
messages from your app
to an application server,
using the same cloud messaging
infrastructure If your
user wants to follow games
of Italy's national team, you
can simply call chrome.gcm send
function to send a
message to the server.
The message can contain up
to four kilobytes of data,
and must specify the address
of the recipient, which
should be to sender ID of
your application server.
Before sending a
message to GCM, Chrome
stores it locally to make
sure it can be retransmitted
upon failure, which can
happen when the user does not
have network access or
the connection is spotty.
Once Chrome is
online, it attempts
to send all queued messages.
And when the GCM server confirms
the receipt of a message,
Chrome removes it
from the local store,
while Google Cloud Messaging
infrastructure delivers
the message to the
application server.
As a result you get
the same benefits
of energy savings and
delivery, regardless
of the network connection
state of the time of sending,
as with downstream messaging.
You can find more details on
how to configure your server
to enable apps through
messaging online.
Just like with
downstream messages,
you can make upstream
messages more time-sensitive
using a time-to-live parameter.
For instance, if
your user does not
get online within a
few minutes or hours,
Chrome can simply expire
and drop the message.
Setting time-to-live
for upstream messages
has two benefits-- it
allows you to manage
your applications queue
size on the Chrome side,
and there is a queue size limit,
and when delivery times out,
Chrome will erase chrome.gcm
unsent error event, which
will indicate that the
message was not delivered,
allowing your application
to respond accordingly.
So this all looks great, but
I'm sure you're wondering,
what's the price?
Google doesn't charge
anything for GCM,
and you can start
using it today.
To learn more about
chrome.gcm API, please
check out our
documentation page.
And remember, Google
Cloud Messaging
makes building efficient
real-time apps a breeze.
Give it a try.